okay guys we're doing a little miss Kay
lanius quest right here and we got to
talk to the debuff brothers the [ __ ]
dyad oh yeah then i got it i think the
owners and i love justice i just love
justice I wanted all right help diamond
city of radio it's terrible yes makes
you want to cut your own ears off okay
yes pretty this is what I tell you feel
either we have unhappy customers forgive
it's true ah someone needs to I don't
think many would sorry there that's
hardly tell you it would be easier than
you complete their tune up your rocker
my name isn't serious he seemed to know
no you mm-hmm what Travis he means well
but he does not have and so he's up he
does not believe in himself um well
exactly go on spoil sport Haram you I
can sense a confidence man this is the
way sure we're doing my boy psychobabble
and my main man tell Jumbo's do this
that synth freakin arms like you
understand me yes yeah we all pitched in
we want you to have this you're a hero
you know that
thank you for finding girls kilo sky
she's hot doc Crocker family Cooper how
does so that I only ever had a deal with
docs son oh I should get your murder
let's see what you have take a look GSS
i get rid all this [ __ ] though I got way
too much shot here the [ __ ] is that
mmm-hmm hell no else is a fat man i'll
need this board I don't know his lasers
Gauss Rifle ass oh yeah that's a is it
matter less hey this is Jesus
yeah it's not [ __ ] here oh shut 75
uh
that is all this [ __ ] coming from chase
ass
okay okay except anyways sorry I have to
do that my own but I just got so angry
you know that groom why should we put on
there enough hug as a background hey you
Fein I'm glad you found girls killer but
now my brother won't shut up about you
anyway do you need the room no no not
today well it's vacant if you it gets
easier with it what the [ __ ] is the guy
that I supposed to excuse me I'm busily
excuse me stop by the office game where
the [ __ ] out here this what do you want
maybe I am glad you're going to come
unlike mine I'd be happy to okay so
Travis needs to be haven't met a man
excellent I want to stage 5 here in
Duggan nothing I want you to be there to
help make it right yeah sounds again
bored why not a high hip cool they
confront Travis here at daughter used it
then you and Travis take them down
nothing simple I have everything ready
by okay I can
it's after six pm okay sit here
okay I gotta put this one gun away
though all right where is it
I wanted so much more from my life than
this the Dean McDonough is gone turns
out he was a see maybe I run for the
mayor one day you know I was once king
of the entire country all whim not right
now you sure oh well hmm ok so happy to
hey there pal oh it's you
I'm here to give ya I don't I I just
wish they'd go away let's stay a side
bang with these men today don't be such
a coward don't ok that's beating oh
that's enough oh I'm sorry you see so I
said I said that's enough leave me alone
Oh see cut you really own town look at
you hmm let me think about that for a
second nah I don't think so leave me
alone sounds like you were thinking
about saying or else were you Travis are
you gonna say or else oh just said
wondering what comes after that what you
gonna do little man get him oh I'll beat
you up big mistake Travis I'm gonna
destroy you and your friend here cat oh
[ __ ]
how did he kill him he's a damn brah
Travis why am I doing this why am I
doing this I'm busy excuse me hey there
Oh God ja good gosh yeah man just
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] man this is
not what I signed up for this ain't over
here me hate it yeah okay hey usually
don't charge you [ __ ] his ass up hey
Travis whoa I know your cut I knew you
had I'm God God God get word what
where's yours yeah hey vide yeah yeah
ready for the next part of food ruphylin
yes yes been on bring it on whoo that
you have seen scattered yes now i am
just simple button if someone who was
not her employer suggest that she go
spend time I could have a chat with her
yeah just do whatever it takes sure you
weren't right okay okay Scarlett oh yeah
oh yeah
I wanted so much more from my life than
this
okay where is that [ __ ]
where is hey brother remember the
freedom trail
what the [ __ ] was that I already did
that quest okay now where's ass [ __ ]
all right CheY yeah CheY sleep on the
floor so uh what touchdown her air she's
hot as [ __ ] oh hey Scarlett I don't want
anything okay actually I Travis oh goody
I heard about the fight yeah you think I
mean I definitely noticed uh-huh oh look
Travis I'll go see him now perfect my
plan is working psycho the match Riker
God can't get get get get get get get
get get get nice piece you got there
little paulik right so nice Thai Jesus
[ __ ] off
yeah k gets his man terrible oh I knew
it he was up to no good and look what's
happened now I have had it to help I
can't do it take it easy they took him
uh-huh those men did the ones that mess
with Dallas he came back he wouldn't pay
and did they grab them and you have to
do something I ran back I'll bring him
back he's just bringing back a heart
attacks
okay I gotta [ __ ] them up their work
then I would [ __ ] about them all right
chaps will [ __ ] you got she's sleeping
hook an [ __ ] cielo date I'd say I'd
say no she's gonna go [ __ ] him right now
what's going on where the hell is bull
that ass I'm not joking wait oh sure no
Travis this is what if I hadn't gotten
into that fight don't beat yourself up
kid look I don't really if a team is
missing all right good I didn't I've
heard enough to know that probably holed
up at the old bean town and then we can
bring the team back oh I'll get a gun oh
god Ken oh hey
good God sorry I don't mean to be a
cockblock but ok
where is this brewery uh yeah I didn't
hear that Travis was such a killer ya
know like I didn't know I like house I
supposed to know you know like crops
coming in pretty good you hear about
that farm run by ghouls the [ __ ] okay
here we go mm-hmm [ __ ] that's him ready
how can I this guy's like fearless let's
go [ __ ] oh thank god you're here so
this is it odds are if they've got Vadim
he's inside where we're gonna be okay
right daph I definitely okay ray uh huh
uh just right
okay whoa what a [ __ ] gun Jesus yeah
we're gonna tear this the psychobabble
okay there's an
all right let specialist okay
gotta get [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] there get up there oh great we
should winter all [ __ ] away and I'm
gonna come back off sigh kind that's
what he's done I [ __ ] his Chavis he
didn't come in I [ __ ] high thank you
I didn't you're welcome you a good man
idiots get caps and Kim's just like I am
surprised to see you here hey Vadim I'm
glad you're safe how did you get roped
into this hey I wasn't forced or
anything i wanted to help me what a day
huh hey listen
I wanted to say this has been gets a
hair you can't fool thanks after all
this time thank you for watching a
camera